captain at this point it's unclear if
the plane was on autopilot or not that
is if the plane computers had taken over
to help land this plane is one way safer
than the other well what we have in the
cockpits now is a technology and human
system and both parts have to do their
roles we have to be a good match a good
fit a good team and certain skills are
attributable to pilots and they are good
at adapting and seeing things for the
first time and still finding a way to
solve them technology is good things
that have been foreseen and can be
programmed so both are necessary there
are technologies in the cockpits that
can help us just one example is that on
the airport's at most major airports
there's a device that will provide an
electronic vertical path to the runway a
very precise one to help us fly the
right approach path to the runway to
avoid obstacles into land on the runway
the proper place unfortunately because
of airport construction at San Francisco
that device was not operable that day so
there was one less technology it was
available to these particular pilots and
so you're saying are you are you talking
about the glide slope indicator which
was turned off at the time but had been
turned off for several days you think
that that could have been a problem I
don't know if it was a problem that's
just one factor it's one bit of
information that they may look at you
have to realize this was an overnight
flight as you said 10 hours from Seoul
and they were landing in San Francisco
about 11:30 in the morning which is
about 3:30 in the morning a Seoul time
the the nadir of their circadian rhythms
the the bottom of their alertness and
performance and their body schedules
overnight so I would have used it had it
been available all the available
resources to help me guide that airplane
to the runway of course the weather was
clear and they could see the by the way
but having that precise vertical path
would have made it a little bit easier
and and they might have helped them to
detect this deviation sooner but that's
it's - or did they say there well we
know that there are there others - there
are the others thank you oh sorry
we know that visual
white rules were in effect does that
mean that the technical instruments are
not being used at that time visual
flight rules means that you have good
enough visibility and cloud height that
you can fly the airplane without
reference to instruments to the runway
of course especially as a pilot who
might not have had as much particular
experience in this particular type of
airplane having an electronic glide
slope would have been an additional aid
so we don't know how an important that
is but that's just one more bit of
information that we know that they
didn't have available to them but there
were other devices or the technologies
available in the cockpit that would have
helped them to define the right path to
the runway but probably more important
that is that we have protocols in place
at all major airlines so that the pilots
work together as an effective team and
they they support and help each other
and they have checks and balances and
they make sure that at certain distances
from the runway there were at the proper
height in the proper speed and we need
to find out what the human factors were
in this case that apparently that didn't
happen in time now captain I know you've
landed multiple planes at SFO I've
landed multiple times at eff at SFO and
I remember I remember a specific time
where we were coming in for a landing
and the pilot aborted and we went down
and immediately came back up and circled
back around multiple producers on my
team have had similar situations is San
Francisco a particularly challenging
Airport well in some ways it is actually
the u.s. aviation regulatory agency the
FAA has designated San Francisco among
other airports in the country as being
what they call a special airport and
that means under our rules a u.s.
airline in this particular case having
someone fairly new to the airplane not
having a 100 hours of experience in that
particular plane type would be
prohibited under our rules from flying
from taking up our landing at a special
airport until they'd gotten a hundred
hours in time for example when I flew
four years ago on the on the series of
flights that led to the Hudson River
landing in 2009 I was flying with
Jeffrey Skiles a great pilot someone who
had been a captain on the 737 and has 20
hours of flying time but this was his
first week of flying the Airbus after
having been trained on it for a month in
this classroom in the flight simulator
and he'd flown the week before with a
check-in I'm an instructor supervisory a
pilot flying with him and when he flew
with me that week it was his first
unsupervised trip on the Airbus and he
couldn't land at some of the airports we
went to because either there were
special airports or because the
visibility was too low or because the
runways were contaminated with snow or
ice and so those are some just some of
the considerations that that pilots have
to deal with and San Francisco is a
special airport because of some of the
procedures and some of the high terrain
not far beyond the airport and captain I
know as you mentioned earlier there are
still a lot of unknowns a lot of
questions to be asked and investigation
that's going to take months if not more
than a year at this point though do you
feel that the crew is being unfairly
blamed you know it's we shouldn't be in
the blame business at all if there's
anything we've a lot learn from an
aviation in the last 50 years is that we
have to transition from the bad old days
when there was a culture of blame and
instead of asking what happened how did
it happen and why did it happen they
would ask what happened who did it and
stop and that course short-circuited the
investigatory process we never addressed
underlying fundamental issues that may
have led to this chain of events the
pilot being maybe just the last one to
be a chain a link in that chain and we
never could do our very best to keep it
from happening again we've learned not
to do that so instead of assigning blame
now what the NTSB does is find probable
cause contributing factors and make
recommendations so it's it's I have two
responses to that first it's way too
early and second it's never that simple
it's it's always more than just one
thing happening going wrong it's a
series of things that in aggregate add
up to a chain of events that leads to a
bad outcome